you can't keep a good scoundrel down Han
Solo may have died in the force awakens
but the character lives on in film
thanks to the spin-off prequel solo a
Star Wars story which features Alden
Ehrenreich as the galaxy's scruffy astir
herder but with more than 40 years of
Star Wars history to draw on solos many
references and easter eggs could be
daunting for fans both young and old
don't worry we have you covered here's
what you need to know before you see
solo a Star Wars story when does solo
take place going by the timeline
established in the official tie-in novel
last shot the action and solo appears to
take place somewhere between three and
eight years before the events of a new
hope so don't expect to see familiar
faces like Leia and Luke because at this
point in his young career Han is a
one-man operation that's going to change
though as the film promises to show Hans
meeting with his right-hand wookie
Chewbacca as well as the galaxy's
smoothest frenemy Lando Calrissian and
that leads to the infamous game of cards
that wins Han his one true love the
Millennium Falcon a game first mentioned
way back in 1980s the Empire Strikes
Back what have you done to my ship your
ship remember you lost her to me fair
and square
who is the Game of Thrones lady playing
Game of Thrones viewers know her best as
Daenerys Targaryen the mother of dragons
but in solo actress Emilia Clarke plays
a very different yet equally badass lady
in the form of Hans sometimes partner in
crime Kira she may look glamorous but
Clark asurs fans she's just as devious
as solo himself
she explained if you've got a really
glamorous lady in a really sordid
environment you kind of know that maybe
the glamour is hiding a few rough roads
the thing that you see with Kira is that
she is an enigma
who is L 3-3-7 in the grand starwars
tradition solo will introduce a new
droid to the Star Wars universe but some
parts of Lando's partner L 337 will look
familiar to fans literally the Droid his
self-made having constructed herself out
of spare parts from other droid models
including bits of BB and r2 units and
protocol droids like c-3po
last shot novel we learned that l3 is
both the committed droids rights
activists and deeply spiritual saying in
the book some guy in a factory probably
pieced me together originally and
someone else programmed me but then the
Galaxy itself forged me into Who I am
because we've learned maybe we're our
own makers no matter who put the parts
together who are the new rogues those
solo has plenty of cameos and callbacks
most of the supporting characters are
all new to the Star Wars universe so you
don't need to read or watch anything in
order to appreciate Woody Harrelson's
criminal mentor Tobias Beckett Tandi
Newtons expert marksman Val or Paul
Bettany's crime boss Dryden Voss fans of
the Star Wars comics from Dark Horse are
in for a treat though as Jonathan Kasdan
and Toby hefferman solos co-writer and
assistant director respectively portray
Imperial soldiers tag and pink bumbling
officials who accidentally play a key
role behind the scenes throughout the
original trilogy classic where's the
fanservice while the whole film could be
considered fanservice there are more
inside references than just the
inclusion of tag and [ __ ]
for instance part of solo is set on a
mud planet of nimbin which was
originally introduced back in the 1978
tie-in novel splinter of the mind's eye
but it's never made it into an actual
movie until now and the tease of other
wookies could signal the return of
Chuy's family though most fans would
prefer to forget it the 1978 Star Wars
Holiday Special introduced to Pacha's
wife mala and his son lumpy bringing
them back would be the ultimate inside
nod for hardcore Star Wars fans who
directed this thing anyway rumours of
problems on set plagued solo right from
the start to help smooth over production
woes Lucasfilm reportedly hired an
acting coach for star Alden Ehrenreich
in broad and co-writer Lawrence Kasdan
who also co-wrote both Empire Strikes
Back and Return of the Jedi to lead
script rewrites and when things still
didn't get straightened out Lucasfilm
went with the nuclear option firing
directors Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller right in the middle of shooting
after a delay of several weeks
Ron Howard came aboard to finish filming
and write the ship okay it wouldn't be a
true Han Solo adventure if everything
went according to plan
what's the bottom line though solo is
obviously intended to fit into the
greater Star Wars universe
fans don't really have to worry about
knowing every little bit of franchise
trivia because unlike the previous Star
Wars films solo is designed to be a
totally self-contained one-shot film
sure you'll get more out of it if you
get some of the in jokes but there
shouldn't be any cliffhangers here just
a big sprawling space adventure
featuring one of the most beloved
characters in cinema that's not to say
this is necessarily the end though if
solo ends up being really popular we
might get more big screen adventure
starring young han that's because alden
ehrenreich is apparently signed up for
three movies so will the film proved
popular enough to spawn a trilogy of its
own if there's one thing we've learned
over the years it's never bet against
han solo thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]